he asks what do you think comics should
stop doing versus what comics should be
doing more of
um i think comics should stop
taking themselves so seriously and uh
and and do more stuff there and unsure
of
if it will work or not a lot of times
comics get into the like
you know uh it's gotta have the perfect
this perfect that perfect this
it doesn't it can be okay i've laughed
at a lot of okay
videos like and that might be enough for
me to want to see more from you so
that's the main thing and you stop
taking yourself so seriously
and stop complaining
so much about what works for other
comics like i
that's one of the things in the comedy
community it's just be like well this
person only got because of that and he
only does this
and then bro but what does it matter
like a lot of times comics our biggest
mistake
we care too much what other comics think
and not enough what audience members
think
comics don't buy tickets they don't have
they even in comedy clubs they usually
get to walk in for free it's an unspoken
rule in comedy if you're a
comedian you get to come in for free
they're not the ones that are coming to
buy your show in charlotte
so care about what the audience members
who actually
want to come see you live care about and
that will be better than
impressing a whole bunch of comics with
which a lot of times there
that's not even consistent across
comedians
i'm focused on my audience thinking i'm
funny not random comedian x y or z
boom anything else we should be doing
more of
um posting
the internet is the new club
it's the new billboard it's the new tv
show
so why are you not marketing yourself
it's called social media
social media let's connect with our
friends and family media meaning let's
promote ourselves
so i think that's the part a lot of us
forget about it is
media it is marketing every day you're
marketing yourself
you know i'm i'm currently beefing with
jonathan mcreynolds
one of my friends from the gospel
industry and i'm gonna let your audience
and my audience in on a little secret
prior to this beef you know me and john
are just playing
we had talked about going on tour
together right so now i'm like oh we got
this little like fake beef going
but if we decide to go on tour in 2022
they're gonna be like oh i remember that
fake beef they had in 2020. i'd go see
that
right so everything i do is with
intention and strategy i rarely just
do anything more than once just just for
the fun
of it yeah and that was actually a
comedian indy actually
just asked are are there any uh future
collaborations with jonathan mcreynolds
so good timing actually we already we
shot an episode with him before our beef
began
on the app so that's one of the first
four episodes of the
real comedians challenge show um that's
gonna
air so of course i don't do anything for
play play joe
everything everything has a reason
behind it hey hot brother and sister
if you love comedy as much as we do here
at hot breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath verse and then watch
more videos to get even more comedy tips